nadia est l'aîné dauda et halima cet
après midi elle est venue avec ses
neveux et nièces se recueillir devant
les portraits de ses deux soeurs au
moment même où toute sa famille est
réunie à paris pour les obsèques d'al
hima
je suis là et halima le sait donc voilà
je sais que tout le reste de la famille
à paris et je suis venu aujourd'hui à la
même heure ou à lima par ses portraits a
posé ce matin sur le fronton de la
mairie sont un vrai réconfort pour la
famille saoud
ces photos sont magnifiques
c'est mes soeurs oui les deux de de
lumière de deux personnes magique de
personnes extrêmement belle de
l'extérieur et de l'intérieur
hier encore nadia était à paris avec
toute sa famille pour voir ses soeurs
une dernière fois ce que j'ai senti est
ce que j'ai vu c'est la tristesse de
paris par contre avec ma famille on a
réussi à se rassembler donc voilà on a
j'ai ressenti beaucoup d'union nous
sommes une famille nombreuse et on a
réussi à voir mes deux soeurs réunis
avant qu'elle ne parte chacune de leur
côté
mais elles seront jamais séparés oda
doit être inhumé en tunisie dans les
prochains jours selon le souhait de ses
parents touchée par toutes les marques
d'attention reçu par ceux qui partagent
leurs souffrances
maman elle a rencontré des familles qui
ont perdu elle aussi des membres de leur
famille et ça c'était aussi important
pour elle pour mon père de savoir et de
comprendre bien qu'ils ne sont pas seuls
en fait sur les marches de la mairie
nadia a tenu à immortaliser ce dernier
moment avec ses soeurs à ses côtés